In order to get to 90% plus close rate,
how much pre-qualification do you do before jumping
on a Zoom with a business owner?
Other than average profits.
Dude, Irving, you and Eugene, by the way,
for anyone that doesn't know,
Eugene and Irving are their partners.
You're gonna get to a point,
and you guys have been doing this for a while now,
but just keep making offers, keep doing Zoom calls.
You're gonna get to a point, Irving,
where you're gonna know with like 98% certainty
whether you're getting the deal or not.
And it's like a soft skill.
It's gonna be impossible for me to say,
yeah, when they say this, this, this, and this guarantee,
you're gonna do enough of these.
And I've done enough where I know by the way
they're talking, the way they're texting,
the way they're interacting, the tone of their voice,
how many leads I've sent them, timing.
I know if I'm getting the deal.
And guys, it's to the point now,
excuse me, it got to the point in late 2021
when we were going super hard.
I, like guys, I didn't lose deals.
Like I just didn't like ever lose deals.
Like you, but I also knew what I was looking for
and I only got on Zoom calls with people who were my fit.
So my advice to you would be,
you guys are doing this already,
take really good notes of like, okay, I closed this guy.
What are some of the things that were consistent there?
Okay, he said this, he said this,
we sent him three leads, he closed one.
And it was over this period.
And I know Eugene's really good at keeping track
of that kind of stuff.
But it's just one of those things that's a soft skill.
You're gonna learn it.
It's really hard to teach it without the experience.
But you guys are doing enough deals.
You're getting up to bad enough
where you're gonna be learning that.